السلطات الروسيه احباط هجمات ليليه شنتها
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه في منطقتي موسكو
وبريان رئيس بلديه موسكو الى الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت الطائره المسيره كانت تحلق
باتجاه العاصمه الروسيه وقد اغلق مطرا
الدوليان في موسكو فتره وجيزه امام
المغادرين والوافدين قبل ان تستانف
العمليات لاحقا من جهتها اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تدمير طائرتين مسيرتين فوق
منطقه بريانس كالمنتخمه لاوكرانيا دون
وقوع اضرار او اصابات
مقابل قالت سلطات مدينه
صناعيه في المدينه واعلنت قياده القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها الجويه
اسقطت اربعه صواريخ كروز من مجموع سته
صواريخ روسيه استهدفت عده مناطق في
اوكرانيا وقالت القوات الجويه عددا من
الصواريخ اطلق من فرقاطه تتمركز في البحر
الاسود وان احدها اصاب منشاه صناعيه في
مدينه بولتافا ما اسفر عن خسائر بشريه
وماديه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه استعاده
السيطره على بلده روبوتينو في مقاطعه
تعتبر بلده روبوتينو مركز الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد
فيمولوجيا وسيطر عليها تعني اختراق خط
الدفاع الروسي الاول في المقاطعه وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها استعاده
السيطره على نحو كيلومتر مربع جنوبيه
مدينه باخموت في مقاطعه واضافه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استعادت السيطره على 44
كيلومترا مربعا من المدينه منذ بدايه
الهجوم المضاد
مصادر عسكريه روسيه سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه على بلده روبوتينو بمقاطعه
المصادر ان معارك عنيفه تدور حول البلده
بين الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني وان القوات
الاوكرانيه دفعت بمزيد من التعزيزات
وتحاول اختراقها من الجهه الشماليه لكن
دون تحقيق اي تقدم
وبسموالنا لروسيا في زابولوجيا صورا قالوا
انها لتدمير مدرعتين امريكيتين الصنع من
طراز برادلي تابعه للجيش الاوكراني على
مشارف البلده
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغام
اذا امين اخر المستجدات فيما يتعلق
بالروايه الروسيه لما يجري
[تصفيق]
نعم مياده دعيني ابدا من هنا من موسكو حيث
اعلن عمده المدينه على ان الدفاعات الجويه
اسقطت طائره مسيره في منطقه لوبرتي الى
الجنوب الشرقي من المدينه دون ان تتسبب او
يتسبب هذا الهجوم في وقوع خسائر وهذه
المنطقه منطقه لوبرتي مهمه استراتيجيا
باعتبار ان مطار تشيلسكي العسكري الروسي
لعله المطار الرئيسي الاول للقوات المسلحه
الجويه الروسيه يقع في منطقه غير بعيده من
تلك المنطقه اضافه الى مطار جوكوفسكي
العسكري باعتبار هذه المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه تضم مطارين عسكريين وبالتالي تعد
هذه سابقه لربما
بتعرض هذه المنطقه الشرقيه الجنوبيه من
موسكو لهجوم بالمسيره اوكرانيه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قبل قليل ايضا اعلنت على
ان دفاعاتها الج اسقطت طائرتين المسيرتين
اوكرانيتين فوق شبه جزيره القرم دون وقوع
خسائر وكانت قبل ذلك ايضا قد تحدثت عن
اسقاط مسيرتين اوكرانيتين في منطقه
الحدوديه بين روسيا واوكرانيا دون وقوع
خسائر بالنسبه للمناطق الخاضعه للسيطره
روسيا في الجنوب الاداره العسكريه
والمدنيه الروسيه فيزا اعلنت ايضا عن قبل
قليل عن تعرض مبنى هذه الاداره في مدينه
اينورجادار التي تقع فيها محطه النوويه
لهجوم الاوكراني بمسيره وقالت على ان
البيانات والمصادر الاوليه تؤكد على عدم
وجود ضحايا في هذا الهجوم قبل ذلك مصادر
عسكريه روسيه كانت قد تحدثت عن ان بلده
رابوتينو في جنوب المقاطعه التي كان الجيش
الاوكراني يتحدث على انه سيطر عليها ما
زالت تحت سيطره الروسيه وبان معارك عنيفه
تدور حول هذه البلده التي تعد عقده
عقده انطلاق
للجيش الاوكراني خلال ما يطلق عليه
بالهجوم المضاد منذ اشهر وتحدثت عن ان هذه
الهجمات تم صدها وان القوات الاوكرانيه لم
تحقق اي تقدم وبثت صورا قالت بانها لتدمير
اليات عسكريه وبان القوات الروسيه تمكنت
من اسرع عدد من
القوات او عدد من الجنود الاوكران في ذلك
المحور الذي هو فعليا محطه يعني يعد مهم
بالنسبه للجانبين باعتبار انه يفصل بين
المناطق التي تحت سيطره الجانبين ويعد او
تعد السيطره على القريبه والتي كان الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا في وقت سابق اي قبل اشهر
الا ربما قد اعلن على انه سيطر عليها وجاء
ايضا بعد ذلك نفي روسي بان القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره عليه اضافه الى هذه
المنطقه تعد لربما قاعده لانطلاق هجمات
الجيش الاوكراني والجيش الروسي يركز عليها
بشكل كبير باعتبار ان خساره هذه المنطقه
او هذا المحور يعد فعليا فتح خط تحرك
للجيش الاوكراني باتجاه مدن هامه
في مقاطعه
الجيش الروسي يبدو انه ما زال يصوت تلك
الهجمات على الاقل بحسب مقالات تلك
المصادر الروسيه فيما يخص دونيسكا رئيس
هذه المنطقه الموالي لروسيا قال قبل قليل
على ان الجيش الروسي حسن من مواقعه وفق
قوله في كل من
منطقه دونيسكا الشماليه وايضا في مارينكا
هذه البلده التي تقع الى جنوب من دون
ايسكو تشهد معارك عنيفه بين الجانبين دون
ان يحقق اي تقدم اي الجيش الاوكراني بحسب
بحسب قوله وبالتالي تبقى هذه الجبهه ثابته
وغير متحركه بالمعنى العسكري لا يوجد اي
تقدم كبير يمكنه ان يؤثر بشكل او باخر على
خريطه المواقع وخريطه السيطره خاصه في
دنيا